what's going on everyone it's alex and
moses here and if you're new to the
channel um
built three companies that did 110
million dollars in sales and continued
to do so
now we invest in other companies as well
um and one of the talks i want to talk
about today is the money ladder uh and
so this was actually came up during a
conversation i was having with layla my
wife
um and she was like you should make a
podcast about this she's like because
you know a lot of people don't know how
this works
and um so right now i'm writing a
handful of books around a one of them is
kind of wealth beliefs that that changed
my life um and then i've got a bunch of
books on acquisition stuff that's coming
out
so what's the money ladder that's what
i'm calling it but basically it's the
order in which people get paid
and a lot of times like one of the
biggest beliefs in my life that changed
as i got wealthier and that changed
before i got wealthy that caused me to
become more wealthy
was how i viewed the flow of money all
right so what i mean by that is if you
look at who gets paid when
right when money flows you can see
typically where where and who is making
who has the most control and who's
making the money
all right so think about it from a
concept of work and payment
all right so at the bottom here you have
an employee in general all right and
there's nothing wrong with this right
ever like i was an employee too
so like it's not that there's anything
wrong it's more so that like this
you just have to understand how it works
from a hierarchy standpoint
what happens with an employee is that
they work first right
they work first and then they get paid
two weeks later
so they front their labor they front
their time and then they get paid two
weeks later
right or four weeks later depending on
what the job is right so
that is if you look at the money flow
they have cost of time
cost of effort that goes out and then
delay
and then they get paid right
now if you've got somebody who's
self-employed
this is kind of like a lot of
contractors vendors gig economy etc
these people typically there's they're
trying to choose scenarios here one is
and
and you can see because these people are
a little bit more flexible you'll see
them kind of move
on this money ladder so on one on the
total
i'd say worst side of the equation the
lowest side of the equation they
basically model the same thing that an
employee would
um that a normal employee would set up
which is they front the work and they
get paid later
right um later you know if they get
better and better and they become
truly more independent contractor type
things then they might get paid half up
front and then half
upon delivery right so it's kind of like
50 50 right
um and then later right
then they start moving up this ladder
some of them will get paid up front or
as they
as they work etc right so the next one
is
paid first right so think about this
if you if you go to a doctor right they
don't do the surgery and then they get
paid
they get paid and then they do the
surgery right and so if you think about
your work like that or your business
like that
you get paid first right now um this is
where like payment plans and things like
that like
the more someone pays upfront
and then i would say like in full right
that's another kind of mini variable
here
right are they paying somewhat a front
are they paying all upfront or whatever
um getting paid first is
another level of kind of wealth and and
kind of control and power all right now
but notice if you're looking at this
from the video
we've still got we still got a little
bit of ways to go up here right
so then about above this right
this is kind of like this is kind of
where i see
people ending and then you kind of get
into like the business
side of it right so um above this you'd
have like banks
right so what do what do banks get
so banks have something called a capital
stack so this is
what i mean by that is when you when you
buy your house
right you're actually the bank's really
buying your house and then you're paying
the bank back
the bank is a preferred creditor what
that means is if
you know [ __ ] hits the fan they get paid
first and then whatever is left over is
yours
right that's how it works that's why you
repay your mortgage when you sell your
house
and then whatever's left over the scraps
go to you
right banks get paid first they're
preferred creditors
and so when you're thinking about like
money in general
look at where the exchange flows right
is
who's fronting time and then getting
paid or who's splitting it up up front
or who gets paid in full right
and then if [ __ ] goes bad who's the one
who gets paid out first and who's left
with the scraps
now i'd say that there's one one thing
above banks here
which i would say is insurance this is
really interesting i've learned a lot
about interns over last year
so insurance is fascinating
insurance gets paid far
before they ever have to do anything
think about that you pay your insurance
for 20 years before they have to fulfill
what they are
do and they also can not end up having
to fulfill anything and you just get
paid they just get paid for 20 years for
truly doing nothing
right if you really think about how the
money flows like really think about it
for a second
imagine you have a business imagine i
started signing people up for an
insurance business you know alex
hormozy you know insurance um
and i just started going around saying
hey i'll ensure your life hey i'll enter
your life hey you enter your life right
and people just start saying sure i'll
sign up and they start paying me a
thousand dollars a month and i've got
100 families
500 families who start paying me a
thousand dollars 2 000
a month i'm doing a million dollars a
month and i do that for decades
right and then as people you know come
to term
because of how i wrote the contracts or
whatever this is obviously a shitty way
of doing it but
candidly it does happen um you know they
might not qualify or they can no longer
afford the fees because i increase the
fees
as they become higher and higher risk
right of actually
me needing to fulfill this stuff so
the point is is that if you look at
insurance it's basically the opposite
of a depreciating asset so when you when
you depreciate a building so you buy
something and then you depreciate in
your tax a lot of people see that as a
good thing it's like oh
yeah we can depreciate it that it's only
a good thing because in your mind
because the tax code
not because it's actually good that
things get old and become outdated right
think about it
so insurance is the reverse of that so
instead of
putting all your capital up front and
then having depreciate something over
time
insurance companies get all the money up
front and then they get to appreciate
the money over time
and then pay you off of that right and
there's a reason that insurance
companies the oldest companies
in the world the oldest ones are you
know 180 200 300 years old
and it's because that is a business
model that is unreal
they even i mean they predate the tax
code they don't have to pay taxes
so um interesting so when i think about
this stuff um
this was uh this was uh hopefully this
is valid to be valuable for you when you
think about
um and you know actually i'll put i'll
put one level above this
the top level
i'll say god and franchisors um
obviously i'm not saying franchise words
are god
it's kind of just being funny don't get
personal all right and so the last level
above this is that
god gets 10 off the top
period for life
and so that's how you can see the money
ladder right
all the way at the bottom people front
their time from their effort from their
labor
they delay and then they get paid they
move up to self-employed
they front their time or they split you
know they get half now half later
um and as they move up this ladder they
get paid more up front right a lot of
that's because of demand
because of how good you are right you're
a doctor you get paid first before you
do your surgery
right if you're if you're a professional
you're a great consultant something like
that you get paid up front
right beyond that you've got
banks who uh they get paid first and
they they leave people to scraps
afterwards so that's when there's a
defined pot of money
above that you've got insurance
companies who get paid the whole time
and then may or may not
ever have to fulfill on their their work
right so them there they get money
guaranteed but the work that they have
to fulfill on
is not guaranteed think about that right
and then above that
you've got god um who gets 10 off top
line
of what you make so um i hope this was
valuable for you this is the money
ladder as i see wealth
and as i've as i've thought of these
things as time has gone
on um i shifted my views around it i
changed the way we did agreements all
that kind of stuff
um and so hopefully you find some value
in it so this is one of the beliefs that
changed my life that um
that made me a lot wealthier is watching
where the money flows watching where it
goes and watching who gets paid when
keeping awesome bye